the death of peter connolly caused shock
and outrage the toddler was tortured and
abused for months and his mother did
nothing to stop it
tracy connolly was jailed in 2009 for
causing or allowing her son to die
in march a parole board decided she
could be released from prison the
justice secretary dominic raab
challenged the decision but a judge has
reviewed and rejected his application
mr raab responded angrily tweeting tracy
connolly's cruelty towards her son was
pure evil the decision to release her
demonstrates why the parole board needs
a fundamental overhaul including a
ministerial check for the most serious
offenders so that it serves and protects
the public
but some say the parole board doesn't
need reforming it has a pretty
remarkable record of success in the task
that it's given
and the task that it's given is not to
decide how severely people should be
punished
is to decide once people have served the
period the court has decided is
necessary for punishment to decide at
that point whether people can safely be
released
tracy connolly who's now 40 was briefly
released in 2013 but sent back to prison
after breaching her parole conditions
this is the house in north london where
she lived 17 month old peter also known
as baby p
died having suffered 50 injuries despite
being on the child protection register
he was let down by the services supposed
to protect him reviews into his death
found the police social services and
health teams all missed opportunities
opportunities which could have saved his
life
stephen barker and his brother jason
owen are still in prison for his death
but after years behind bars tracy
connolly could be free within weeks she
served her time even though some say it
wasn't long enough laura bundock sky
news